soy muy buenos días Así es ha habido una
demanda de que los votos estaban
contando de manera doble aquí en
Filadelfia Así que esta misma mañana ha
habido una reunión de urgencia a primera
hora de los trabajadores electorales
aquí en el ayuntamiento que están viendo
detrás de mí y se ha probado un proceso
cuyo nombre es Reconciliación de libro
de votación es un proceso que lo que va
a hacer es garantizar que no haya votos
dobles repetidos los eliminará Qué
problema va a traer esto que ralentizará
todavía más que conozcamos hoy o mañana
el ganador de estas elecciones de hecho
uno de los comisionados electorales ha
dicho que entre 15.000 y 30.000 votos no
se contarán esta noche Así que
imaginaros cómo puedes ralentizar esto
el proceso hace ya cinco horas que
abrieron los centros de votación como
este que es el ayuntamiento os decía
también es un centro de votación sabemos
que ya han votado los dos candidatos a
la gobernación porque hoy aquí como un
36 estados más también se decide al
gobernador y también han votado los
candidatos a ese único escaño que hay
del senado sabemos que el demócrata John
federman lo ha hecho a primera hora de
la mañana en Pittsburgh junto con su
mujer y el candidato republicano también
ha votado a primera hora de la mañana ha
dicho que está muy contento con la
campaña que han llevado a cabo ya ha
felicitado el trabajo de los
trabajadores electores electorales por
otro lado Cuáles son los temas que más
preocupan a los ciudadanos de este
estado péndulo no tan clave para los
resultados definitivos
si hay tres temas muy importantes que
están en la cabeza de todos los
ciudadanos de Pensilvania que hoy han
ido a votar uno es el aborto la
inflación y el aumento del crimen por
eso es muy importante que salga a votar
y por eso dicen el comisionado electoral
que se espera batir récord de votación
este año Comparado con otras elecciones
de medio mandato Y eso que no está
haciendo nada fácil aquí en Pensilvania
porque no ha sido nada fácil tampoco
encontrar trabajadores electorales
porque había miedo e inseguridad de
hecho esta mañana nos contábamos que han
tenido que aumentar en 250 dólares el
salario por más de 12 horas de trabajo
porque resultaba casi imposible
encontrar esos 8.000 funcionarios para
los más de 1.700 centros de votación que
hay aquí además también el 1 de
noviembre un juez dijo que no se iban a
contar los votos que no tuviesen la
fecha correctamente escrita ayer mismo
el demócrata John federman hizo una
demanda Federal para que estos votos se
tuvieran en cuenta así que bueno como
veis un estado muy decisivo que está
encontrando muchos problemas para votar
pero que sí que es verdad que se espera
que tenga récord de participación